you think the country based on a
christian religion or
uh a peaceful religion does better than
a country that doesn't have a religion
uh well you know there's there are
studies on this that
uh the more uh religious
a
nation or society
um the less healthy the society is now
how is health measured quantitatively
what we're talking about here are things
like um abortion rates teen pregnancy
rates std rates homicide rates suicide
rates
um you know like infant mortality
there's about 15 of these different
characteristics and a social scientist
named gregory paul
did this massive correlational study of
like the top 20
uh industrial democracies in the world
as measured and then measured by their
religiosity as measured by
you know what percentage of the
population says they believe in god they
attend
church services you know every week they
read the bible every day and so forth
and you know basically it's an inverse
correlation the the higher the
religiosity the lower the rates of these
um
social health measures that is to say
like in america is a standout you know
we have the world's highest
among these 20
democracies
you know we're the most religious but we
have the highest rates of homicides
highest rates of suicides highest rates
of stds
pregnancies unwanted pregnancies uh
abortions you know t uh teen uh problems
uh infant mortality and so on now each
of these i have to say parenthetically
each of these has an independent
series of causes that have nothing to do
with religion
but my point is that if religion is such
a great prophylactic against social ills
that if a society needs it to be a
healthy happy society how come it's the
opposite in america we're the most
religious and we have the most social
problems of any of these countries on
those measures and
so to me it's like it's whatever
religion's doing it's not doing that
it's not helping
so you think your country is better off
without without a religion absolutely
yes really
yeah yeah as long as they have of course
you got to have some kind of social
safety net you got to have a set of
standards and values that people go on
so my christian friends say yeah even if
every no one believed in god in america
we're still a judeo-christian society
from historically okay that's true so so
then you would much rather trust in a
man's values and principles that dictate
the country than a
set of principles based on a book or a
bible
you'd much rather have a man lead your
country really oh yeah because
i think about the constitution yeah and
the enlightenment values
this this whole centuries-long
experiment has been one of
of saying regardless of whatever your
religion is these are the values we hold
that we that people are are born equal
that is of equal value and should be
treated equally under the law
and we're going to abolish slavery and
torture and civil rights and women's
rights and gay rights and all the things
you know we've kind of experienced in
our own lifetime
at least came about
because of this central principle of
interchangeable perspectives there's
nothing special about me or my religion
or my race that that makes me better
than you and your religion and your race
are equal uh is
in terms of value so that is an
enlightenment principle no religion came
up with that and in fact religion has
come up with quite the opposite you know
that our religion is the one true
religion and back to where you were
talking about earlier in the
conversation you know all these wars the
ones you personally experienced growing
up that's because of religion's conflict
with each other and no means i think
it's the complete opposite though i
think it's the complete opposite i think
what you're saying is
you know what america was founded on the
constitution you know where they got it
from
you know where they got it from well
okay uh you're gonna say they got it
from the bible but no actually the
founding fathers were mostly deists
uh jefferson hamilton no i'm not gonna
say the bible but do you know where they
got it from okay go ahead i'm curious
i'm asking you but what do you think
they got it from what's the history
so the constitution did they come up
with these did they get problems
all of them were classically trained so
they knew history they knew greek and
they knew the history of greece and
particularly rome so if you read the
federalist papers for example there is
just example after example between
hamilton and madison of uh examples from
ancient greece and rome and they knew
these histories and then of course
they're the products of the
enlightenment they were in the
enlightenment you know so
you know john locke and and
john jacques rousseau and thomas hobbes
and all the thinkers that kind of
particularly locked that that led to
this division of
of uh separation of powers because and
if you read the federalist papers
they're very much steeped in human
nature they start off going like what
are people like people are selfish they
are power hungry if you let them they
will take more than they need do you
believe that
oh yeah totally absolutely so if you
believe that if you believe that how
would you trust more
of a man coming up his values and
principles to run your country than a
higher power that you can't change it
because the higher and i'm
purely talking from a logical standpoint
yeah but the problem is how do you know
what the higher power thinks i hear
here's a part of me there's a part of me
that actually doesn't care
there's a part of me that you but you
have to care because i'm going to ask
you well where'd you get that particular
idea you got to say what comes from
well here's why let me explain to you
why let me explain to you so how sure
are you about your beliefs
about what about the fact that you think
a man created god not the other way
around i'm reasonably confident and sort
of a bayesian say i'd say 18 to 90 okay
great you think there's people on the
opposite side that are also at 80 or 90
percent
i'd say there's religious people that
are a hundred percent yeah i would say
yes i think there are so much to me the
atheist argument is the most famous no
no no no no the atheist is just a lack
of belief in god it doesn't mean the
strong atheist it says i know there is
no god is not a tenable position you
don't know there is no god all you can
do is put a probable that's right we're
on the same page there yeah yeah so
agnostic to me is the one that says you
know they they don't know right but the
atheist says i know there is no god well
the weak okay there's a strong atheist
that says i know there is no god that's
not a terrible position in my opinion
the weak atheist says i just don't
believe in god
now there might be and if i could change
my mind or you know i might find out
later but okay for now i i i just assume
there isn't and unless proven otherwise
okay but that doesn't tell you anything
about what somebody believes
you know i would say well what do you
believe in well i believe in civil
rights and civil liberties and i believe
in love and you know whatever
that has nothing to do with atheism
completely there's but there's one thing
a religion that's 100 percent proven
that's proven it's 100 right you know
what religion that is
the religion of i don't know
okay all right yes or no i mean that's
that's 100 proven so meaning
meaning you can say you believe in jesus
he can say he believes in prophet
muhammad she can say she believes in
whoever i can say guys listen we can sit
here and fight all we want and put
events together in halls and gather a
thousand people and sell 100 tickets and
you and i can debate all day long and
the answer at the end of the day is what
neither one of us know right okay so if
we know we know that's the only hundred
percent
is that we don't know let's set that
aside if we know we're going off of
you're never going to be 100 right i'm
never going to be 100 right till we die
we're not going to know right so as long
as we're living and we have the religion
of i don't know
what do we want to base the country off
of let's pick a manual this manual
called bible works we have the bible
what's the book that elrond hubbard
wrote dianetics we have the quran we
have the book of moroni whichever book
you want to pick we have pick any of the
books we have buddhism you know great
book i've read it that's very to me it's
it's it's
if i wasn't a christian i'd probably be
a buddhist you know let's take all these
books let's take uh meditations by uh
what do you call it by uh our friend uh
the stoic system marcus aurelius right
martin luther king
yes
let's pick one of these books michael
and let's build the foundation of the
country of this one person and let's not
even look at it as a god let's look at
it as a philosopher and a way of living
don't you think it's better to pick a
book of a person that's not alive
to go live life off of that than a
person that's alive that can all of a
sudden have a meltdown and change and
become a dictator
no the the
the correct the correct answer is
you don't base a uh you don't base a
constitution on any book
no book the whole point of the us
constitution what makes it unique
amongst all political systems ever
invented is that it's not based on any
book it's based on a set of principles
derived through reason and then open to
change
you know as as madison said ambition
must be made to counteract ambition
people have their preferences
the jew the christian the muslim they
each want as much power as they can get
so we have to have a rule in there that
says nobody gets to have any
state-sanctioned religion there are no
religions state sanctioned by the state
full stop you can believe whatever you
want but it can't influence our
political system done okay next you know
well i you know that my race should be
the superior race okay well we kind of
messed that up in the with the slavery
thing but but you know we got that
eventually solved through a civil war
and so on so but but so the whole
principle is based on ideas not
people's
books not holy books not revelation
you know you can't if you were to write
a new constitution today you wouldn't
start off saying well we begin with that
jesus is our savior and died for our
sins because jews and muslims would go
hey hey hey we live here too but america
was founded based on judeo-christian
values and principles do you know that
roughly speaking
thomas jefferson being a side
you know
but again read hamilton and madison read
the federalist papers there's no god in
there there's no bible there's no
religion these are all just ideas so so
was there was there god for george
washington was there god for uh
why she was a he was a diaz but more of
a believer than jefferson
yeah
was definitely not but but but but it
doesn't matter what the founders
believed it doesn't matter it's the
ideas right they came up i told you
about it yeah oh i totally agree but
like you know
kids going to school would i want the
kids go to a school
that are based on a certain
values and principle that's a higher
power than a man i don't know if
from my record anybody you've given too
much power to you've heard the quote
before power you know corrupts people in
absolute power right need to repeat that
you've heard that a million times i'm
just too concerned about giving men a
little bit too much power absolutely so
if you like this sort of short clip from
an interview i did click over here to
watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]